hold on there partners before we get
this show started we got a real special
announcement from down here in aunt
doody's basement
uncle hank and kippy a couple of city
slickers are going to be heading out
down south
we're going to be at raleigh good nights
in north carolina april 20th it's coming
up
the next night we're going to be in
zany's nashville so get some ticks
yeah guys it's going to be a good time
we're going to be doing some live
stand-up t-bones coming with us
and then we're going to be doing uh some
live ayg with you guys you guys are
gonna
give us questions we're gonna be asking
you questions uh so grab some friends
come on out
it's gonna be fun we're gonna be
[ __ ] on your stupid uncle ted or
whoever comes your buddies
your buddy steve who's an [ __ ] it's
gonna be a good time correct don't be
showing up with sneaks and no socks on
we're gonna rip on you we're gonna we're
gonna be having some beers we're gonna
be taking some pics we're gonna be
hanging out
we'll see you there now let's get the
show started
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
i'm h foley and i'm an [ __ ]
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage
goddammit oh yeah
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a rainy day we're down here at aunt
toddy's basement
uh love is in the air in the springtime
oh yeah kevin james ryan is trying to
play a little matchmaker
oh yeah with a uh a former guest
bodyguard sure and aunt hoodie well he
was waiting out by the car and she saw
him
he was waiting out by the car we tried
to get her down to ac
right and she came back earlier because
she found it touched the chinatown bus
back
took the chinatown bus back because
somebody neighborhood told her that they
saw chas palm and terry in the
neighborhood
and she put two and two together and
zipped right back
i gotta tell you i like it it's a match
made in heaven i like it lamb chops and
toady baby lamb chops and tooty
she deserves to be happy yeah you know
doesn't she
hey at least that i like the idea and i
know you i know you i know you
you you really want it to happen which i
think is beautiful oh yeah but we just
think romantic we gotta like we got i'm
a hopeless romantic folks that's me
kippy
is that a glock in your pocket
[Laughter]
give it up for my co-host the ceo of are
you garbage
international businessman kevin james
ryan
i still don't understand the root of
that uh intro that credit how do your
wife's german
yeah okay hey let's talk about good
enough for me
international house of pancakes for you
and now that you have that business card
yeah that business credit card oh man
they got some
kids got some steel took me out on the
town last night got me some oysters
i died one more margarita i was going
home with you i'll tell you that
and he what's up everybody trying to
explain the world trying to explain the
world of business expenses and
write-offs to foley is like he might as
well be talking to my dog
i yeah he's like well whose money is
this
[Laughter]
he's like technically this is all money
right i'm like dude just shut up and
enjoy the [ __ ]
oysters rockefeller for like an hour i
believe that toddy was an actual person
and we were somehow we were somehow
ripping her off
yeah he was like i don't like the sounds
of this i don't like it
uh hey what's up gang as always thanks
for tuning in baby we [ __ ] love you
we love you there's a lot of the podcast
love yous uh we appreciate all the
support uh please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video is
available on youtube and as everybody
knows those numbers
are true the roof true to [ __ ] roof
true the roof
true to roof uh and then also guys
patreon.com you can sign up to get bonus
episodes of ayg that are only
existing on patreon without releasing
them out to everybody they only exist on
patreon so you can sign up
you get all of them back until like
november when we first started this
so you sign up today you can get all of
them there's uh episodes of hard
feelings which is me and foley behind
the curtains a little bit get on that
that's a good time baby that's a runaway
hit uh then also we'll do a live stream
every uh every month with the top two
which we got one coming up
coming up yeah it's gonna be a good time
a couple of beers with them i feel like
we haven't seen the fam in a little
while i know
and the [ __ ] road shows what's that
the road shows are going to be like an
extension of that like i'm
i'm now excited because you know like we
get excited we get to do we get excited
digital
cause they're a good time everybody's a
good [ __ ] everybody's a good [ __ ]
everybody makes fun of each other in the
right way
and we're goofing around and they're
laughing and we're laughing and i feel
like the [ __ ] live shows is just
gonna be
a big extension of that of course of
course so guys so raleigh
next tomorrow this is this is coming out
monday right
so tomorrow we'll be in raleigh uh north
carolina
for 20 nights yup and then the next
night wednesday 4 21 will be in
nashville zany's get those tickets the
link will be in the description of the
[ __ ] show never been to
nashville can't wait either have i
look at i've been to raleigh but i was
all
i was only there for a night my buddy
was hooking up with some girl that lived
there
i won't drive from bluebell
i can't get his wiener wet in delaware
where he was good [ __ ] what do you want
to tell you
no it was when i was living in north
carolina and we drove
we drove out to raleigh for the night he
ended up meeting her at a bar
and then the three of us he was probably
a [ __ ] warlock
a raleigh too i don't appreciate these
judgments
my friend was actually a tall
good-looking kid with a little bit of
cash
and she was some she was some rich chick
that lived in raleigh and like a condo
by herself
she's a little screwy i
what were you doing i was sitting on the
couch all [ __ ] all yammed up why he
was in the back doing his business
let me tell you something talking to the
cat baby how are you doing that ain't no
ego boost
no i knew uh being the third wheel on a
[ __ ] hookup
yeah tough break what are you gonna do
how about our [ __ ] producer
extraordinaire
that [ __ ] who's that you come on you
know the magic man he's absolutely
fantastic
been working his ass off and buddy we
love you tebo mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everyone what up boys yeah i went to the
maps with the audio yesterday
yeah yeah chaz was a little bit off the
mic for the listeners toby had nine feet
off
toby had to work his magic over there to
get chaz to sound pretty good also
shout out to mr palmertown shout out to
me if we seem giddy or whatever or if
you missed last episode we we jazz
palmitarian last episode this is the
first episode
we're recording after that we were super
happy with it he was amazing
super happy you guys have been little
school girls all week i know it's been
adorable it's been fantastic the big man
came in tear it up
he said these exact words guys we made a
man in blue bell very proud
we did it fellas i thought he was joking
my dad loved the episode my dad's a big
chess paul i'm a terry fan obviously a
big fan of a bronx towel so he loved
this that made me very happy
and the response from you guys yeah i'm
happy everybody's saying one of the best
apps is not the best app
yeah yeah very cool was just cool to sit
down with somebody like that we had a
great time and it was fantastic and we
thank you again for the love and support
and this back to the roots is a family
episode
you know what i mean you have big
company in sometimes it's good you just
want to [ __ ]
the wagons a little bit you want to
rewind with the unwind with the family a
little bit you know everyone's gone home
we got our showers we got the homework
shoes are off that you know the
kitchen's cleaned upstairs we had the
coffee
now we're gonna sit down as a family
watch a little tv maybe maybe you're
married with
children or something like that we
weren't a lot of watch out in my house
oh
sunday night was there was a run
of sunday nights just tv in general when
we were kids
that was [ __ ] blow you away sure yeah
sunday was like the simpsons [ __ ]
married with children pga friday wasn't
that something too
yeah that was your nice thing that's see
i'm i'm too old for that too busy
sitting in condos in raleigh
i got time to watch family matters i was
trying to make a move on this cat over
here i was too old for that
yeah i think if i remember at the time i
was pushing for the uh
menage a trois to no avail
yeah neither one of them was probably
interested in that you guys all right in
there
[Laughter]
you guys good tell you about i'll just
be i'll i'll be over here just let me
know
i'm thinking like a sexual appetizer
sampler what are you guys thinking
maybe we could split these fries huh and
by the way you're out of mail
um family episode here we're [ __ ]
back together we love it
as you know when you sign up for patreon
we get a question asked on the air
yeah that's what we're gonna do here
today uh-huh guys
um so yeah we got we got some [ __ ]
heaters too cold water by the way thank
you yeah they opened up a new spot down
on the corner it's open
yeah nice ain't gonna go all around the
block oh just they tell you i feel like
i'm in the [ __ ]
in the old west out here it's wild
brutal i gotta walk three blocks to get
a [ __ ] pack of gum let's go
yeah now the place opened up right right
on the corner it's pretty nice too
um and we got the mini fridge and we got
the mini fridge cookie you haven't
noticed gang
got the mini no one really said much but
we got the mini fridge here patreon
dollars at work yeah i gotta go right
back into the product i got a couple old
bud heavies in there
that are decorated with christmas that's
how old they are i know but just think
those things are getting colder
and colder you know and cold but they
were worn they were sitting over here
for about two or three weeks i know but
i'm i'm that guy
if you can get it cold enough it's fine
of course that's not gonna do anything
was it cold it's not gonna get skunked
right it happens yeah that's
that happens lift it in the bushes man
it's gonna be skunked that happens
is that i remember when that was my
biggest concern in life yeah
that beer is going to be skunked man
you're like doing inventory you're like
well i got three milwaukee's best over
by the pond
i know yeah you pulling [ __ ]
house you can get this or whatever yeah
looking like a real [ __ ] idiot yeah
don't tell nobody i got a 30 rack in a
snow bank
yeah absolutely fantastic but what i was
going to say is uh
i'm one of those trash bags that thinks
the longer that it is
in cold the colder it's going to be
you know that doesn't even make sense to
me like like okay so
so if it's in the sun it'll get really
cold when you put it in no no no i'm
saying if you leave
a if you have two let's say you have two
capri suns
you you put two for the [ __ ]
scientific method you're breaking out on
you put you put two in the garage i was
more of a high c kind of guy but sure
i'll live in this world with you orange
yeah orange and fruit punch okay we had
always had both
because we're [ __ ] we were [ __ ]
learned people you talking about the
little bangers the squares
the recces the three packs i used to get
well no we would get that we would get
like the 12 pack
and put the fruit punch and the the
orange in there i would get about two or
three of them a thing of [ __ ]
yeah i think a goldfish head right up to
the room
dad don't talk to me if he's
busy and i would i would sit on my
inflatable chair that i bought i got
paper
i got paper i got paperwork to do don't
bother me yeah oh
dude the inflatable chair they were big
spencers it was blue i used to sit on
that thing
yeah it's a real pool thing like a pool
no it was like an inflatable chair that
for like
your house i mean i'm sure you could use
it in the pool but science says you can
it'll work in the pool
probably beat that i wasn't on like i
wasn't like a [ __ ]
like like a mat that you would take down
shotgun falls or anything
i was on a proper [ __ ] blow-up chair
a two-seater raft
it's got the handles on it the one that
just looks like an alligator
oh man we've had an alligator in our
pool
it wasn't a raft i can't get that little
[ __ ] out
[Laughter]
we gave them the chicken but those
things are a good time i'll tell you
that that's trash as [ __ ]
have an animal shape blow up yeah you
get a noodle and like a tire that's
it the noodles stink [ __ ] noodle when
they when noodles dropped
there's only one thing to do with the
noodle beat the [ __ ] out of each other
put your wiener in a little hole
anyway back to my experiment what i'm
saying is if you keep two high
cs all right you put two ics in a garage
fridge
you wait two days you drink one of them
okay
if you waited until the end of next
summer to drink the last one that one
would be colder
does that make sense yeah that's not how
it works i know it would have to freeze
at some point no
yeah yeah well yeah no it can only get
as cold
i mean if you turn the air conditioner
on for it it can only get
a week it's not gonna be [ __ ] 15
degrees in here i know but it feels
nicer for some reason does it you're
telling me that a [ __ ]
high seat that's been sitting in the
garage for all summer ain't going to be
something
well i don't know i mean i don't know
what it says about my family but they
made the [ __ ]
they were they were in a main fridge
we had high seas in the main common to
think about it it's dangerous
we only my dad didn't have a second
fridge this whole time
wow give me the company card holy [ __ ]
that's
rattling we only had one we were one
fridge people jesus tobias
that explains so much oh
he was more of a cooler man we had a
couple of coolers rolling around yeah
it's all right
yeah but wow i didn't realize that holy
[ __ ] that just rattled my little [ __ ]
world
we went back on the brush of the teeth
in the shower no garage fridge this
guy's white trash coat switch
or lion to us the whole time maybe he's
maybe he's the real crazy one
um microphones aren't even plugged in
truth be told i didn't have a garage
fridge until
we moved into the house that there until
we started the patreon
i'm not quit getting on craigslist
kippy's got an id and it looks like it's
working
um yeah we didn't have it until we until
we moved into the house
that we're in now which was in 19 i
don't know 87 yeah i thought that's
[ __ ] 30 years ago
yeah yeah that's fine it's respectable
it's respectable
yeah got a garage switch for 30 years
not too shabby it's not bad
and if you leave something in there for
a long time it's going to be really
really cold that's my point
and you got a couple of [ __ ] butt
heavies sitting in there yeah yeah i'm
going to crack them
i want to do a proper drunk episode but
you two bozos don't drink anymore i had
the beta blocker
yeah i didn't stop you from house and
[ __ ] well margaritas last night
we were on a classy establishment too
he's like what
it was kind of a place where they were
like was i gonna get a [ __ ] diet coke
like an [ __ ] no will you at least say
some sort of tequila you don't go
he was like well what well all right
dude
no one's ordered the well of the well at
that joint in a long time i'll tell you
that
i never know what to say in those
situations yes i don't want them banging
me out
you weren't paying for it that's what it
was cody's got to let her beat
i guess i should have said uh what's
this what's the square one
the kind of score don julio just make
something up
yeah you got you know you got the uh old
bag a door back there and he says no
i'll be like ah give me whatever you got
i got to find a tequila you're right
because anything but jose cuervo
sure anything but jose cuervo all right
my blood run cold
yeah i gotta figure one out because casa
amigos that's the go-to i'm gonna be
drinking a lot less these days
okay when i do it's just gonna be one or
two cocktails like a gentleman
which i'm starting to realize is pretty
nice puts me into a perfect spot
yeah you know what i mean
i um three last night three beers i went
home and got a six pack of pounder pbr
this is christ
[ __ ] house them john yeah you had
three beers you had three [ __ ] german
boot pints whatever the [ __ ] they had
i don't know what that was this guy's
hazy too you couldn't see
through that that's murky and water
right buddy you're flying blind in that
thing
visibility zero may day may day hippies
ipas
i like it like a churning river
it's just like a boat engine that's
stuck in the mud you could lose an
eight-year-old in there like that
definitely a couple of gators in there
oh yeah
a couple of ipa gators
[Laughter]
i'll have the chop ipa please no
chop like on the water yeah whatever one
too far
that's a classic foley one that no but
not even that it doesn't hit we're all
like what are you even talking about
there's one for the back of the room
it's like we're even in the same joke
what's going on here's one for nobody
i'm not even really sure if i get it yo
everybody alive
can still recall one time when you were
like 15 teenage years hanging with your
friends
and you threw out the one too many joke
that killed the whole
yeah that was backwards most of them
ended that was back when the term
beating the dead horse was big all right
you're beating a dead horse remember
that
i got hit with that the first time no
i'm not 115.
beating a dead you've never heard that
what am i an [ __ ] of course i have
okay that's all i was saying we weren't
here back in the day
no we you weren't saying it there's no i
wasn't saying that there's no you don't
know what i was saying
i hope i know what you were saying it's
just a couple holy [ __ ]
without a garage fridge trying to make
his way in the world well two in the
bush one in the hair
whatever none in the hair
ah let's get to some [ __ ] family
questions here gang by the way
what we say this what do we say and
other podcasts say this about how much
they love their fans and all that stuff
yeah but these guys
are [ __ ] funny sure the jet ski
question
yeah home run the one that you got on
patreon i know that [ __ ] which i just
forgot about i'm pulling that up
dude because there was one on patreon
well this is what we'll start with
because toby doesn't know we know it
and how we how i heard of it was so
funny there was one on patreon that my
buddy shout out to my buddy pat
texted me and he's like dude this thing
[ __ ] leveled me do you know this
no he literally just said i didn't yeah
yeah this one's choppy huh
you got it yeah this one's from krishna
i'm telling you i was laying on my couch
facing the other way away from the tv
laughing for about literally five
minutes straight oh you're really
[ __ ] happy what's up if it doesn't
happen
chris jean's gonna look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm sorry before you dive into
this there was one comment on the
chas episode that [ __ ] killed me
where the guy said
chaz may have a bobby lamb chops but
he'll never have a johnny [ __ ] balls
i also think johnny chipball's just
changed his name to dr johnny [ __ ]
i swear to god i got a question from him
yeah dr johnny ship balls that's awesome
congratulations yeah
mazel tov my finished medical school doc
but everyone
when everybody said a [ __ ] balls would
never amount to anything you proved them
all wrong there yes sir
i'm the first [ __ ] pulse to ever
graduate in college
yeah you guys are [ __ ] awesome oh
it's so funny uh this is from chris g
ever been ran over
no have you been have you ever been ran
over
ever been random have you been rhino
have you been ran over
have you been ran over which i mean
that's it's i would have never thought
of that to be a garbage question but
it's
oh man if you're getting run over you're
doing something wrong yeah for sure
i mean i mean i guess the kennedys but
that's a bad getting hit by a car is a
tough look dude
they made my size hurt dude look that's
a tough look shout out to chris that's a
fantastic have you ever been hit by a
car
uh no that's not the question have you
ever
almost seems intentional
yeah there was motive behind it there
was men's reya
you left the vig a little too long you
know what i mean
run him over there's that son of a [ __ ]
get him
yeah take the beginning of the sopranos
yeah if you're pulling a marcellus
wallace
on somebody when john when uh
god damn it gotta get you a netflix
account i got one um i've been
had my foot run over yeah that's
actually the the we we got to the core
of why kippy doesn't get movie
references
well because he's just watched a bronx
sale a thousand times he's never watched
any other movie yeah bronx tale and band
of brothers on repeat this guy
two great programs drinking drinking
ipas and smoking during the movie
[Laughter]
hey whatever well [ __ ] tequila who
orders well
tequila come on you're making me look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] over there
it was probably jose cuervo to be honest
with you that's a nice joint their well
is like top shelf at the places i go to
oysters are fantastic it was a good meal
yeah it was a nice time we're going to
be saying we appreciate expense
um yes uh i've never been
i've been pinned between my car
and another car i was i just it was it
was the first time i was doing comedy i
went down to helium comedy club
in philadelphia you [ __ ] suck
[Laughter]
no you suck give me another list will ya
have you had 20 minutes it's my first
time
[Laughter]
hey gang the weather's getting better in
this spring you're gonna get back
outdoors and explore
take bespoke post on all your adventures
with a new lineup of essential box of
awesome collection for you guys
guaranteed to upgrade your life if
you're not familiar
bespoke post it's a website they got
awesome stuff for guys they got it for
your house they got it for outdoors they
got it for travel whatever you need they
got it
they shipped me a duffel bag and it's a
home run i'm taking it on the road on
the weekend
i'm all over the place with it if you
need something to upgrade your home bar
to pro level heights bespoke post only
sends guys the best up
every month no matter what you're into
box of awesome has you covered from
style
grooming bar ware cooking tools
outdoor things whatever you want they're
taking care of you it's easy peasy
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box for you uh they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel at any time it's easy
peasy they're not hounding you're not
breaking your back
hbox only costs 45 bucks and has over
70 dollars worth of gear inside you're
losing money in my book
where i come from that's a no-brainer so
you get 20 off your first month
your first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com and enter the code
garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome.com use promo code
garbage for
20 off your first box today gang our new
sponsor helix sleep has a quiz
that takes two minutes to complete and
matches your body
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress
for you oh yeah why would you buy a
mattress
made for someone else i wouldn't you
don't have to because with helix
you're getting a mattress that knows who
you are
and knows your perfect fit and is going
to give you the perfect sleep
everybody's unique all right and helix
knows that you know
they're not idiots they're not idiots
you know what they're doing over there
at helix so they have different
mattresses and different models to
choose from
they have soft they have medium they
have firm mattresses they have mattress
that are great for cooling you down
at night they have mattresses for
keeping you warm at night even helix
plus mattress
for plus size sleepers oh baby the big
man
uh guys they they they hooked us up with
i got it me and my wife took the quiz
and uh i was matched with the twilight
model mattress and i gotta tell you baby
this thing is like sleeping on a cloud
it's fantastic you're gonna have to come
over and try it out one time if you want
oh i will
next time you're out of town uh i've had
a lot of i
struggle sleeping with anxiety just late
nights
you know sleep schedules all messed up
the noise in the city and
i've been having some of the best sleeps
of my life
since this thing came last week i
believe it's students clean
living on that bad boy so if you're
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress that you've been
matched to and the mattress comes right
to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to the mattress store ever again
and also who wants to be going to a
mattress store in the middle of coven no
can't be laying on a mattress with other
people might as well be laying on the
subway take the quiz
yeah it's easy be close it comes in a
box right to your door you open it up it
pops out it's real cool helix is awesome
you don't need to take my word for it
helix has uh
awarded has been awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick
for 2020 by gq and wired magazine that's
two heavy hitters baby these ain't just
no bums off the street it's crazy
yeah uh so just go to uh helix.com
garbage and take their two minute sleep
quiz it's easy peasy
and they'll match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life i'm telling you
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free no
questions asked that's a steal they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it
but you will so helix is offering uh up
to
200 clams off all mattresses ordered
and two free pillows for all two three
pillows and two hundred clams off what
are we doing
you're gonna have to get in on this go
take the quiz yeah uh
if you go to helixsleep.com garbage
that's helixsleep.com
garbage for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
gang if you're having issues around your
house if you've got squeaky doors
clogged sinks uh
finicky engines anything like that what
do you do do you let it go
no it's the roof's leaking do you let it
leak like an idiot and just lay there
like a [ __ ]
you take care of it like a gentleman
that's right you take care of it so when
it comes to things in the bedroom
why would it be any different so what
you want to do is you want to go to
getroman.com
garbage right now yeah guys with get
roman
uh you can get a free online evaluation
and ongoing care for e.d
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home you don't need to be meeting people
no making eye contact no waiting room
a u.s licensed health care professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan that's
tailored to you and if medication is
appropriate it ships right to you
for free with two-day shipping and
that's what's fantastic about them
if medication is appropriate ain't
pushing it on you if you don't need it
they take a look and they give you a
human being first yeah and that's pretty
rare these days that's fantastic the
whole process is very straightforward
very discreet no one has to know about
it getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com
garbage and complete an online visit
take care
of your ed without ever leaving your
home complete an online visit and
connect with a health care professional
to take care of it for you
so guys this is what you need to do go
to getroman.com
garbage now go right now and you'll save
15 bucks off your first month that's
cash we're talking about baby we ain't
talking percent we're talking cash
it's really time to take care of your d
and remember
get started today and you'll save 15
bucks off your first month of ed
treatment by going to get roman.com
garbage now back to the show my first
time doing comedy i drove down to
uh in the teego rest in peace took to
teego sure that was a real fun relaxing
ride down
that was the start of [ __ ] 11 years
i didn't know you yet i was still happy
[Laughter]
it's like i got alopecia the next day
you're in a convertible with an ass cut
on
i'm not smoking a pipe
meet you next thing you know what
pawning my [ __ ] you're getting pinned by
your car
yeah oh how does this happen there's no
hills over there
in your mind the car went off by on its
own yeah
how do you get pinned i'm gonna explain
it to you yeah we've never heard this
story so i go in
and you sign you had to show up at like
six right show at like 7 30 you signed
up at six
you signed up at seven they posted the
list so i went and i signed up
for whatever and i go back to then check
the list
later at like seven or whatever sure i
parked right out in front
there was a black car in front of me and
i walked in i'm on the list i'm so
[ __ ] hype i'm like oh my god
i made it this is you know and my buddy
flip and ralphie are in the teego
and uh i like i'm like looking at them
and i'm like yeah this is
this is [ __ ] awesome and so i now i'm
walking i have to go between the cars to
get to my car
and the car behind me is a student
driver
like permit learner's permit with his
[ __ ] nana who's
out to lunch like she shouldn't have
been [ __ ] she shouldn't have been
there wait student driver i mean they
had to sign on no but like a kid
like a young like permanent like he's
got his learner's permit he was like 15
acne and [ __ ] i should have [ __ ] i
was about to flex on him
so he backs up
while i'm behind the car and pins me
and i don't think he knew he was in
revert like i don't think he knew he
took his foot off the gas
so now he's pinned both of my legs
between my front bumper and his rear
bumper and like stayed there didn't like
back up
no he was i don't the only thing i can
decipher is he didn't know his foot
wasn't fully on the brake
and he moved back slowly because he
wasn't paying attention
did it hurt yeah [ __ ] hurt what do
you mean i got [ __ ] pinned by like a
saturn ion or something
that's [ __ ] embarrassing i'm trying
to start my comedy career
[ __ ] all the comedians are looking at
me like what the [ __ ] this fat
guy doing with a great head of hair
right
[Laughter]
right in front of the club you're
probably like i'm gonna see if i can bum
a cigar off that
guy you're sitting there eyeing me up so
i started [ __ ]
i was in the back seat of the old way
punch in the car because i'm like
i panicked when i panicked i panicked
yeah that's a panic so yeah that's a hit
the [ __ ] panic
i'm [ __ ] oh my god the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ]
and i'm like now i but nothing right
it's even harder
i guess he had subwoofers or something i
don't know what was happening he wasn't
hearing my cries
so i go what the [ __ ] dude so my buddy
flip then leans over and he starts
pressing the horn to be like
cause now i'm making eye contact with
flip like so
somebody's got to do something here and
then they i was like what the [ __ ] are
you doing he's like i got my learner's
permit nan it was like
drooling oatmeal on her face what was
happening oh she would have gotta talk
then i went in killed bomb for 10 years
then started this podcast
that's funny i was never my dad got hit
by a car when he was a young kid
running across scott street or something
like that
where you live yeah there's one is one
arm's a little bit shorter than the
other oh you just told me that yeah it's
trashy
have you if you have to get custom suits
not because they're expensive it's so
funny it's such a fascinating thing and
i remember every time that i thought of
it
i would always make him show me and i
thought it was the coolest thing ever
yeah but it never cool the guy it never
really came up that much it was weird
you think
i'd be making him do that at like
parties and [ __ ] like that dad dad get
over here
show me a closed growth plates
[ __ ] dork but now just i've had my
foot run over
and it you know what's crazy thing if
you get your foot run over it really
doesn't get infomercial for bad shoes
it really doesn't hurt that bad you
would think it would really really hurt
but it didn't hurt really that bad at
all it was more scary
thinking that there was going to be
searing pain yeah but there wasn't it
was like a honda accord too
and there was like three or four people
in it and it rolled over my foot real
slow
there's a lot of jokes there that i'm
going to choose not to make because i'm
trying to be a better comedian
ah i've never been hit by a car but i
was run over by a boat
oh my god was it in the ocean no it was
in a lake
lake norman north carolina dude
yeah why because we were on the boat we
were like going wakeboarding and [ __ ] i
would have been like
12 or 13 maybe maybe 11. and
we were the i was like can i jump off
and they were like yeah and i was on the
front of the boat and i
jumped but my dumb ass didn't go
sideways i went
forward so i like hit the water you
jumped off the front of the boat while
it was moving
and then what do you [ __ ] seal team
six what's wrong with you everybody
knows to jump off the back or the side
well i jumped off the front in the front
and then immediately got hit by the boat
went under luckily boats are v-shaped so
it just popped me out the side
the second i went under did you feel the
propeller like the that's that was the
thing i was like propeller
yeah no [ __ ] propeller propeller
propeller and it i was lucky i was
wearing a life jacket so it just sucked
me right back up
popped me out of the side like the back
of the side of the boat propeller didn't
want me oh
man the life jacket makes it even more
lame too
dude nobody looks good in the live chat
oh it's tough stuff
i did i think i'd rather drown i swear
to god
i've always told myself i'm not putting
one of those things on especially one of
those things on the airplane that blow
up
he'll choke the [ __ ] out of me yeah yeah
say chris farley
there is a weight which i've been before
which you look
better with a life because it's kind of
like a shirt you know what i mean
it's like a flak jacket yeah because it
covers everything you know what i'm
saying but like if you guys
can look real tough on a jet ski yes
that you can look like a football player
or something
like you're in g unit yeah exactly yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
uh you look pretty good right in
comparison to the
that's the alternative that's the neck
roll move in football you put a neck
roll yeah it looks like you're getting
oh
i have like six of them look like i was
in queen i swear to god it was awesome
uh yeah that's but i had that but the
orange ones are tough
dude stop they were all like dirty and
did you ever did you have anything i
feel like
have you ever had to put on a wet and
already wet life jacket
dude i purposely didn't we went to the
when we were in hawaii for christmas we
went to this waterfall and you can go in
there and swim
but it was a little more touristy night
than i thought it wasn't just like
you know two people yeah yeah like so
they had like a whole setup and you had
to put
a vest on i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
putting that on all sweaty
some kid from belgium [ __ ] just
taking it off wiping his boogers on it
and [ __ ]
yeah that's what i'm gonna do yeah yeah
it's a tough look um
i i feel like they're worse for you too
i feel like you're better off on your
own
you just [ __ ] float tread water they
don't really this is why we don't pay
you to think
i'm just saying man i feel like you're
shark bait you're just a little [ __ ]
bobber up and down
no thank you for the rest of the
population they make you float whereas
you still sink
yeah that's true i'm a good swimmer
though and i float i guess i say the
bodies that's 78
water so that's right i can hang her in
an olympic-sized pool
i've had to make that joke before i got
enough sure of it i got a big event this
weekend
i need a couple more kids with a snack
bar if anybody's interested
uh um all right next what do you got
next question this is from
frank uh thank you frank have you ever
bought presents at the duty free shop
i don't even know what that is really
yeah it's like
some sort of tax you're not paying
because you're technically
no sales taxes yeah if the navy exchange
counts than i have
the navy exchange the navy exchange is
like uh almost like a target that's on
uh military bases where dependents and
uh
that's a little service members can go i
think i assume that's probably
catch a break you have something yeah
yeah we used to buy liquor there for
parties around the holidays
yikes never stocking up that week for
christmas
[ __ ] fantastic jesus christ i was
coming back from mexico and i got sniped
by a guy at a duty free shop in the
airport
i was walking and he sniped yeah yeah i
was walking and there was like a guy in
like a vest like he looked like a like a
like a cartoon wolf he was like had a
vest and was leaning against a wall like
like in my head he's smoking a cigarette
but we're indoor he wasn't but he just
goes
my friend tequila and i was like what he
goes duty-free and i just went yep you
got me
yeah all right i'm in jesus guy john q
did you even know what duty free was
no i was just i was like 18 and i was
like i can't get booze in america
smart oh smart thank you smart smart man
uh not bad t-bone i've done it a couple
of times
i've only bought liquor and bernie's
when i
need them is this like a delaware run is
that duty-free
no that's no sales tax duty-free is
something i i forget exactly what
how much are you saving i mean how much
could it be a couple of bucks on a
bottle of liquor probably that's stupid
i got the uh definition right here
duty-free refers to the act of being
able to purchase an item in particular
circumstances without paying import
sales value-added or other taxes
yeah so it's tax-free so if you're
buying like a 50 bottle of liquor
35 bucks yeah probably 40 something
come on i know but that's the big thing
is when you're stu they got you pretty
good when you're at the airport
mm-hmm you're sitting there for two
hours people are like i guess i'll
[ __ ] shop it's like no man's land you
know what i mean who wants to be
carrying
[ __ ] more [ __ ] around with them i like
to travel light
you boys are about to see that on
tuesday yeah well our tickets don't
include [ __ ]
carry-ons or [ __ ] or check luggage so
we're all traveling very lightly you
have to check that it's my phone
how am i gonna play one on my wallet
what do you got us on by the way
east wind shut what east winds i'm not
kidding what is this wings
[Laughter]
what's that man that's great i know that
one's going to be like a little puddle
jumper plane it's not going to be from
raleigh to nashville i'd have to assume
it's going to be [ __ ] it'll be a
regional jet yeah
i don't i don't like the sound of that
if he's going to be like my uncle's got
a plane boat
we're going over on the spruce goose
[Laughter]
here they come now yeah that's why we're
only going to cities dexterity
how do you guys feel about zeppelins
i [ __ ] feel real good about it we're
toured in a hot air balloon
where's the show it depends on which way
the wind's blowing nah
i gotta find out what the trade winds
are before before i lock in the club
looks like we're going to miami folks i
like the zeppelin idea
they're rolling around in that thing so
you guys use analytics to book your tour
no no no no no farmer's albany yeah
there's supposed to be a full moon
tonight
um yeah never a big duty freak i have
bought some stuff when i've been in a
you know when i've needed it if i was
going somewhere where i'm like oh we're
going to like a wedding or a party and
i'm going to stay with a bunch of
friends
i'm like yeah i get a pack of [ __ ] i
get a carton of bernies
and you know like a bottle of jameson or
whatever but like with it
with the intention i'm going somewhere
for this sure you know are you gonna get
a carton of bernie's in north carolina
no tax on tobacco
that's pretty good it's not bad i think
i might get a u-haul
really do it up nice
we're gonna be driving back
[Laughter]
um great question next one this is from
andy is it garbage to not have a primary
pediatrician as a kid
yeah man it sounds like you didn't have
health insurance how do you not
like [ __ ] you moving around like a
game of three card monty or something oh
man
i rocked him i rocked out my
pediatrician till i was like [ __ ]
at least 18 or nine yeah i was driving
to the pediatrician oh a hundred percent
yeah shout out to dr barbara shout out
to dr dr john rogers fantastic
yeah yeah john rogers does not sound
like a doctor though he's a fantastic
doctor
john ryan sounds like a mechanic it was
not you know what the private eye here
yeah yeah
exactly express lube and pediatrician
that's funny please i'll give you 200
for it the kid okay
i like the private eye that's good um
there was something about the p
obviously the pediatrician's office was
way better the toys to this to that
it's a little more colorful sure the
treasure chest is there
yeah but the birds were always smoking
hot the girls that worked there
or you thought they were you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah as you got into
your your formative years you started to
you know what i mean that's the first
couple of times you flex should
be a little flirting
[Music]
my mom's outside i'm an adult now she
can't come in how are you done
no i still want the car yeah thank you i
look real big in these tiny chairs
i want to buy one of those i've always
wanted to buy one of those treasure
chests
oh i'm sure you can order those
somewhere that have all the toys in it
remember that it's not plutonium what
the [ __ ] it's a cardboard box that says
treasure chest
i'm sure you can like you crack the case
on the dress i was so hooked on that
oh man that in a nice lollipop nice
dum-dum
oh shout out to a dum-dum shout out to a
dum-dum uh
perfect this one's from this name is a
bit kooky
karthik ah young gothic
karthik uh this i mean this is a
no-brainer have you ever peed in the
ocean
after having more than a couple of beers
on the beach oh man
i'll do that with my fat like we're all
like we'll be on the beach and there'll
be like 30 of us like
aunts uncles and i'm like just like two
dudes just like
you know like walk in stand like 15 20
feet apart and pee and then come out
of course chester river sandbar like so
it was like three feet high
river kid chester rivers
we went once on my cousin's husband's
boat
towards that long ago within the last 15
years
on a boat it was all right drove out
there
miller lights standing in like nice cool
water i mean it was pretty trashy yeah
it's trashy yeah i think you get on a
boat to get off the boat and stand in
the water
being able to stand there the miller
lights were ice cold yeah that's all you
need
forget about it crabbing on a boat with
a couple of ice cold
[ __ ] cores or something a nice hoagie
nice turkey hoagie for lunch
extra onions but yeah that's that's
fantastic
uh this one could never poop in a body
of water
i know dirtball over here has i
if i needed to i could i mean come on if
i need it to
yeah make an omelette out there of
course
yeah i mean i don't think i've ever just
been in a position where i'm like
there's not a house or a restaurant or
something i can go to you know what i
mean
i'm not i'm not a [ __ ] animal at a
restaurant
well i mean like if you're on the down
the shore there's no reason to be
[ __ ]
in the water at the jersey shore do you
ever remember your mom walking into a
restaurant with you
like can he just use the bathroom
on your little face you gotta come in
with me your little fat ass is a huge
dump in there and he used the bathroom
that was always tough
it was just some like boss boy like i
got gas
what a little fat he's going to want to
dare to join up
dinner with a family the bathroom is the
fortress of solitude dude
just a little escape [ __ ] you guys
don't do that [ __ ]
i like my family oh we have a good time
yes it's family's bonkers
to make sure the mcmullens the new drama
on abc
huh yeah um that's
nuts no i would never do that i bet
there are tons of listeners
who sure who will add it out to dinner
go take a little breather reset
in the back oh there's nothing wrong
with that or reset maybe with extended
family that's what i'm saying yeah
okay all right did i ever tell you i was
in i don't know if i ever told you it's
not like you couldn't look your dad in
the eye
i love my dad you son of a [ __ ] you
never loved me
uh i was in italy with my wife for her
hus for her husband's for her brother's
wedding i would have been in the
bathroom more than i was at the table
this is way different i thought he was
talking about i know
i have a story i'm saying and i was
fighting with my wife
over [ __ ] something there's nothing
worse than the fight
where you're at an away game sure that's
bad
i'm in a proper way when you're fighting
with her and she's
and she's with her crew so luckily her
friend i don't know if i told her her
friends
uh her brother and brother's friends are
like a year or two older than us so
they're like and i hang with them every
time wherever so like
there was like four of us just all got
that down at that one end of the table
it was like 20 person table
i mean we're just like [ __ ] we're
like [ __ ] dash chugging beers i don't
know
i'm just imagining you with her german
family who are notoriously humorless
and so your superpower is out the window
oh yeah yeah your [ __ ] charm is gone
it's all gone bombing yeah yeah yeah
yeah this goes real political yeah
how do you guys feel about trump huh so
i go into the bathroom to be like oh
[ __ ] this whatever
and uh splash some cold water i pee
and european toilets are different and i
can't
what are they upside down
how different i'm telling you i couldn't
find
the flush so you never been back at this
dump again
i know i watched i might have [ __ ] then
oh god i forget i
needed to flip stir and dinner i don't
know it was it was
i was i was jet lagged i was all over
the place it was you know it was in the
morning for me
uh so
i had to flush the toilet and
i don't know what to do and there's this
red
chain and i'm like there's no way that's
it what does it stop the restaurant
i'm like i'm like uh-oh
[Music]
i'm like there's no way this is it but
i'm looking like i'm like i'm like
there's no button or why would there be
a random chain hanging down
i don't know what i'm like what was the
name of the restaurant jigsaws
my father-in-law was chained to the
radiator why would that just
be there i want to take a [ __ ]
i'd like to order some appetizers
there's poison on the end of that toilet
paper
yeah it's kippy's dump
whatever lufthansa served for dinner
i uh so i'm sitting there and now i'm
also i got like
six in me so i'm like ah you know and
i'm like this is
i'm like there's no way this is it man
you did you sure as [ __ ]
onions peeling on this guy sure is
[ __ ] at dinner drunk
what the [ __ ] i was it was [ __ ] you
know it was super early for me
let your hair hang down over there i
pulled it and like it was like
i pulled this cord and i guess
i'm like oh this ain't [ __ ] good it
was like if someone falls in the bat
like if
an old person falls in the bathroom and
they can't get up they pull this how are
they supposed to get to it
i don't know the guy finally came in not
happy
no english yeah it was a bad scene i had
to go back to the table
i'm like you guys hear that and they're
like what uh let's say it was [ __ ]
it was like the first night i got there
so it was a rough [ __ ]
trashy yeah
wash your face in the chemical sink
i'm drinking out of the bidet it is what
it is man i'm a human onion people
garbage um all right this is from
brandon uh
is it trash to bring liquor in a coffee
mug to your kid's baseball game no
you're an alcoholic
depends what time the game is i would
say and if it's a social event
i grew up going to gate where like
oh dave people were drinking on the
sidelines i mean we can't compare what
our parents did to what people are
supposed to do now yeah they're
functioning
yeah i feel like now would be a no-fly
but then also feel like my brother right
like i don't have kids i mean think
about the amount of drinking and driving
in our childhood
i don't know what you're talking about
ah yeah it was a different time man
different times sure dude
for sure the seat belts weren't even no
seat belts no airbags
yeah still making cars out of steel yeah
you can't compare it
yeah these days but like what if the
mom's there and all the dads are there
having a couple of beers i was gonna say
let's discuss let's map it out i think
we can i think we can walk through this
that's all i'm all right with that
because i'm a big fan as you know of
in the right setting a cocktail
makes everything better and really
really brings out the moment
fantastic yeah so does [ __ ] nine of
them
and my kid hit two home runs yeah a
couple of dingers
uh yeah i don't know i i remember i
would go to my my brother's my brother
played for like you know
like one of the club team in philly
soccer and trav it was like that was
like the main thing
all over the [ __ ] place every weekend
and these guys
would just bring coolers of beers and
just sit in this game and
dads yeah they weren't just randomly
watching [ __ ] fc coppa or whatever
uh they would bring [ __ ] big red
igloo coolers and just [ __ ] sit in
the stands
like saturday at noon just [ __ ] like
bud heavies and i remember my dad being
like that's a lot
you know what i mean he's like that's oh
that's something he wouldn't even do
yeah he was just like yeah i mean yeah
he was just like it's nude
like i got [ __ ] to like yeah i can't
just be [ __ ] getting plots
at noon heavies when you when you said
it my mind went to
like a situation of like uh like where
my brother
uh had lived like the baseball fields
are like a walk away
you know what i mean sure the kids are
still young enough where they have
one baseball game yeah at 11 on a
saturday yeah yeah
all right um maybe in the morning they
went and got their haircuts he ran the
errands
that night they're going to a cookout or
something like that sure you got nothing
to do you grease the wheels a little bit
absolutely yeah big fan of that you know
what i'm you know what i've become a big
fan of
over over the last year is bailey's in
coffee
yeah big fans nice i'll drink it
straight it's nice this is where the
issue lies
all of that you just described are
people who are openly drinking and this
is someone who's talking about hiding
the booze
that to me sounds like someone whose kid
tucks them in i mean
hiding i mean you just you're i mean you
also it's like you're not celebrating i
see what you're saying yeah who's
business
you're just not celebrating yeah if
everybody's like hey we're all drinking
here that's fine but if it's like
i'm trying to be somewhat respectful and
i'll be honest with you i
i'm starting to think that people do
that a lot more than you think
yeah i think people a lot of people in
my family do it more than i think
i think it's called afternoon coffee
yeah a lot more people have a drink in
them than we than we think
oh yeah i've seen mad men trying to turn
this place into
you guys just come in i'm drinking
scotch i don't know how those guys
getting on toby
from 18 to 27 i never once had a water
bottle with water in it
yeah really toby was upset i was i never
did that real
dirtball yeah proper i like it
and that's why i understand you saying
you know that that's alcoholic behavior
which you know i would agree with that
uh
as well yeah but it's whatever player
loose baby you know what do you mean uh
this is from our boy dr johnny [ __ ]
uh have you ever been a part of a scared
straight program
i always wanted to be though i feel like
foley would have done that but not as a
kid
as like an actor who responded to a
craigslist
he shows up my favorite line ever i
think it was maury or something or was
one of the scared straights they end up
in jail and he's like
or he's like you're talking about the
famous clip with the little kid with the
glasses
where they're hanging them up to the guy
in solitary i forget the peel is orange
nice now oh my god i think it's unreal
yeah he goes what are you in here for
and he's like smoke smoking weed and
he's like smoking weed
smoking weed i smoke yes i was like that
guy [ __ ] parties
there was two threats when i was a kid
one was
uh one was everybody checked to see
who's it was who was the guilty was it
toby no
it was my computer yeah does anybody
know who was yesterday
was the beep on palm and terry's episode
that belonged to a one mr
kippy kevin james rock because i i think
it might have been me i think it was you
yeah yeah yeah well my mine was
because it would have came up on my
computer as well and it didn't and if it
wasn't me
i would mine would have been off
eventually too because i had mine not
not turned off because you're not a
[ __ ] professor you're an amateur i
apologize
you're making me my new best friend mr
palmeteri look like [ __ ] [ __ ] i
apologize to the audience
um and make sure you check out the chaz
palm and terry show
sure yeah absolutely fantastic um
what the [ __ ] were we just saying we're
talking about [ __ ] scared straight
yeah there was two threats when i was a
kid there was going to st
gabes or st michaels whatever it was
called that's freaky the home for boys
yeah and there was uh even more scary i
don't know why because
for some reason it went so far as i
think somebody came to the house
and showed me a video of it like it was
about to happen
of outward bound you know what outward
boundaries heard of it yeah
it's when they like [ __ ] take bad
kids out into the [ __ ] mountains
shoot them with some loose cannon and
like make them [ __ ]
climb over mountains and [ __ ] like that
to get like their confidence and
all that stuff or whatever i'm gonna do
it to you next weekend
next time you come in here there's gonna
be a [ __ ] drill sergeant but some
dude came to the house and gave us like
a little thing on that
that that almost out 20 years later it's
your dad's accountant or whatever
just like you know does your dad give an
extra 50 bucks
hey come over here and scare the fat one
will you
that's all you can wear my old navy guy
you got a cop uniform yeah
get over here uh i never had that we had
we were i wasn't that kid though no i
wasn't i mean i wasn't like i wasn't
caught like that yeah [ __ ] amateur
hour i would get
t but well tebow went to [ __ ]
boarding school like a weirdo yeah he
was a [ __ ] goober
i played sports that was all that was
that we as long as we kept
her we know it was 50 years ago as long
as we kept our cool and didn't [ __ ]
show off we could do whatever we wanted
behind us yeah it never got caught me
got sent to boarding school
so i didn't have to go to school in a
trailer and link it to north carolina it
was to better me as a human being
fair enough okay there you go really
worked out
[Laughter]
cue eye roll your skate or die t-shirt
tells me different but okay
um this mask intruder i always there was
also i'm sure a private school or two in
that area
you know how far where was it in lake
new hampshire massachusetts and where
did you live at the time north carolina
yeah they didn't love you yeah
they they weren't fans of the muffin
yeah they wanted to get rid of you
no there had to be a catholic school or
a private school somewhere near that
between there and boston how about that
but foley i was an independent butterfly
who needed to spread my wings at a big
hippie dippy boarding school with no
[ __ ] grades
go get a refund because it didn't work
and now your careers are in my hands no
way
i get homeless pimping here in two
minutes yeah he's
full schedule yeah oh yeah he is slammed
fingers i would never get rid of t-bone
what
this come on we're [ __ ] nirvana what
do you mean this is a little three-piece
i'm gonna kill myself in a couple of
months
i already got the shotgun never
um wait does that mean that makes me the
[ __ ] bass player
chris nolan no no what is it christopher
selleck
yeah let's say we're all dave grohl
that's pretty cool that way it's even
we're all dave grohl
we can't all be dave yeah we can we can
all be dave grohl
now it's our nirvana kurt can hang
around
i'm going to kill myself i'll be pat
smear i hate that guy you're
crazy his face in every band get out of
here
this guy was in 15 bands in the 90s for
like a half an album
hit the bricks he's fantastic all right
back to the [ __ ]
let's go come on um never been a part of
scared straight
that shit's trashy yeah i had friends
that like had to go to like in-school
counseling and stuff like that because
they got caught doing this or caught
doing that
no i never got hemmed up in any of that
i was never in the system ours was
always uncle den's gonna come up and
[ __ ] tune you up uncle den
yeah i got an uncle denny's a [ __ ]
bad man pajama
that's like what you would be threatened
with if like your grades were bad or
something what would you
no i was always talking back my grades
were never bad what would you have to do
to get him to come up there
he never did obviously yeah but it was
just like i'm talking back or like on a
wednesday night like no i'm not doing it
man
yeah she would say i'm gonna where did
he live
uh north philly junietta or something
yeah he wasn't
i mean he could be there in 35 minutes
with a [ __ ] with a more blight and a
[ __ ]
a 24 ounce coffee from wawa at 10 p.m
there was once or twice wearing it it
was the threat it was like
you know that or your dad like obviously
it was the dad too but
yeah she was by herself and it was me
and my brother running the [ __ ]
asylum you know what i mean yeah there
was once or twice
that brawl didn't stand a chance poor
poor denise
he got tied up like home alone i know my
mom had to deal with us
when my dad would travel you know a lot
it's it's it's it's it's tough
yeah it's a tough look the uncles got
called in once once
once or twice my uncle michael my uncle
joe come in
was always they were always scarier
because you know you feel like you
couldn't score points to them the way
you could with your dad
of course that was like yeah keep
[ __ ] with me uncle dan's gonna come
up and [ __ ] tattoo you
yeah you didn't want uncle joe or uncle
mike either yeah coming and
straightening you out
uh no all right this one's from cass do
you wash new clothes before you wear
them or do you just pop the tags and put
them straight on
this has come up on the podcast b4 um
i like to wash them before but now it's
different because
i'm scared you know i got like three
washes and it doesn't fit anymore
all right but i need that you need that
first wear but yeah but i'm not a fan of
the way t-shirts and [ __ ] [ __ ] feels
it feels like oily before washed yeah
it's bad um
actually it's real itchy i always think
too like what if somebody tried this on
right before me and then i'm way like
true it's like taking someone's shirt
off
on the subway and putting it on i'll
tell you what i do like fresh
fresh pair of socks yeah i always go you
i don't
the [ __ ] wash socks get everywhere
popping nose popping a fresh pair of
those it's always great
um sheets too i found that you were
supposed to wash i never always washed
the shoes i never i hate that oily
feeling i never knew until my wife was
like you're not
gonna wash them i'm like no that poor
broiler they wash them at the plant yeah
i'm like nobody's ever slept on them
what do you mean wash them
do you ever trust pre-washed lettuce or
anything like that yeah spinach i do
sealed spinach you trust triple watch
yeah yeah wow
you trust it yeah trust it this morning
she's been cheating my brains out but
kid's leaking he always catching a coli
batch with the spinach or the iceberg or
something oh yeah
goes around through the midwest whacking
everybody poor schlubs
dude [ __ ] bad matchy kid
patches spring mix a bad batch of 50 50.
they always they do it every year to us
[ __ ] for like the first half of the
summer it's always something
don't go near the watermelons yeah don't
touch the romaine
um this one's a [ __ ] i can't believe
this one hasn't
come up touched in any way this is from
oliver
ah man [ __ ] have you ever unscrewed the
lids on a
on a pepper parmesan or chili shaker at
a pizza place and then set it back on
top and left it for the next guy
to dump overall and ruin his pizza maybe
once when i was 11. yeah it's a trash
movie
i thought he was gonna say cause my move
is i don't do the shakers
i always take the lid off and and shake
it like that
especially with with uh with pepper i
take the pepper thing off and sprinkle
it sideways
pepper yeah like not the red peppers
like actual ground
black pepper yeah or whatever the red
pepper still i don't like going through
the holes
the only one i go through the holes with
the salt and usually i'll put it in my
hand and then put it on
because i like to know and i like that
like let's get this done here
let's do this yeah so you're like und
doing stuff that seems like a longer
process you're saying it's really
[ __ ] this like a [ __ ] jerk off i
unscrew it and i use the lid as like a
little
like as a little stop it seems like way
more work to me no
am i crazy yes right yes but you're
unscrewing screwing
you can just do this just like that a
little twist
maybe especially with the palm yeah
you also you also have control issues
he needs that barm on regulation
he's got to take the governor off baby i
like a lot of parmesan
my buddy blew my mind as a kid at a
wendy's you can't do it anymore because
they don't have the same setup but back
in the day at wendy's on the table they
had plastic salt shaker
plastic pepper shaker and business cards
on the tables so he took a he took a
penny or like a dime or a quarter or
nickel whatever
spun it took the plastic [ __ ]
salt shaker i hate this kid already
slammed it down
on through so the the coin went through
the bottom
okay use the business card slid it under
and then put it back
so the next person to grab that [ __ ]
thing just
dunked salt everywhere jeez diabolical
yeah dude who are you dr evil yeah i
know
yeah yeah yeah that's shitty i was going
burn frogs after that
[ __ ] dorks but i was i was such a
[ __ ] i was like
let's go [ __ ] the comic book store on
fire next i think we're going down a bad
road here yeah he calls dave thomas dave
i gotta talk to you
charlie put a hole in the bottom of the
salt and a business card on air there's
a flaw in your security
nobody eat the chili nobody eat the
chili
hey calls like inside man i'm gonna walk
right out of the front of that wendy's
um excuse me is there a whistleblower
hotline i can contact
with this whistleblower hotline
[Laughter]
i hear the spicy nuggets are dosed
[Laughter]
you didn't hear it for me i'm not t-bone
mcmuffin
ah trash uh we did the scared straight
this one's from tony p
i love how they how they ever like they
have you ever not
just ever have a sports team branded
credit card
[Laughter]
i didn't even like the checks back in
the day i'm like what are you doing
real unprofessional yeah give me a check
with [ __ ] clowns on it or whatever
hit the [ __ ] bricks daddy oh no
but i don't mind i remember when i was
waiting tables if i if i saw like a
philly are you from philly yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's nice uh my mom used to
have her picture on her credit card do
you remember that
oh my god she had like a headshot you
ever as a server which i've never seen
anybody else with that ever maybe that
was like an 80s thing it was in that was
an early 90s thing yeah it was like an
extra security thing yeah and as
a server it was always weird when
somebody's credit card on the back said
ask for my id ask for id yes lady i
i've never been asked for my id ever no
the [ __ ] the matter with you
lady i don't give a [ __ ]
it's a salad shut up that's my bait well
your infringement on my bet yeah
that's your bit yeah it's a salad shot
oh the credit card
credit card i don't care oh your
department store joker yeah which you
can see that and more
april 20th at raleigh good night's and
april 21st sure
and sandy's nash uh this is from pete
new member
uh this is you know he's got he's got he
submitted three
i typically usually pick the best but
he's got two two decent ones really two
two decent ones let us here first one
did you receive us saving bot
savings bonds from family members when
you were born
oh yeah and i cashed them in when i went
to college those just came up on
somewhere where i saw that did do those
still worked
those still did they still happen i
don't know what you mean
do they still have savings bonds i'm
sure you can buy a u.s savings ban yeah
but i thought there was something
that we bought when we were kids that it
was actually useless
was it saving or war it wasn't war bonds
what year were you born
were very the war 1812 there was
something that was big when we were kids
that really didn't turn out to have any
value maybe it was savings well you get
the money back there was no like real
gained interest i don't believe okay you
know what i mean it was like
a 50 savings bonds and then like i
cashed it in it was worth like
61. 35 years later to be so annoying
getting those
yeah fully scrambled i was like i ain't
got no savings bonds but here's some
gold teeth from the enemy
[Laughter]
you like fingertips
i always hated that because it's like
the fifty dollar savings once you
you can see the toy in front of you and
it's like now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of course yeah
i'm starting
i am slowly going with my niece and
nephew straight cash
yeah i doubt my my my the oldest
no more presents i gotta go this weekend
again i gotta do gifts tomorrow
but for christmas the oldest nephew
he's about to start getting cash he's
like 9
10. cause let's be honest and it's like
[ __ ] i
i hit him with a like a 100 gift card
for like
mike for xbox live version i think gift
cards you can buy coins or something
gift cards just as good
get whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
that's why you got me guessing you know
what you like like
let's be honest with each other i know
what i really wanted when i was a kid
sure you know what i mean yeah
especially i'm not talking when you're
like
you know eight or nine but you start
getting 10 11 12.
yeah you want you you want cash i don't
know if it was me or my brother but it
was one of our girls i think it was me
what i
was thinking was my graduation and my
uncle gave me a trapper keeper i was
like yo
bozo just finished yes where's the cage
you think i want to show up to [ __ ]
orientation with a trapper keeper i
could have used this four years i need a
couple of [ __ ] clams in my pocket
you ever get hit with the two dollar
bill ah i got one at home yeah
the two dollars i tried to spend it this
is how poor we they were a little classy
back in the day no no i did the same
thing i tried i bought booze the two
dollar bill
and the ow you've used one i tried i got
denied
you got to know she did yeah dude the
cashier looked at me like what do you do
when your grandma gave this to you
ah it was brutal never this is worth two
dollars and three cents
i used i was that's how poor it was i
was working in new rochelle
and taking the train up every day i was
[ __ ] hemmed up bad on money
sleeping on [ __ ] my boy's floor
and i knew i had i found a two dollar
bill in the apartment i'm like oh i need
this
and i took it and tried a different
desperation yeah i tried to buy like a
water a juice something i don't know
what i was buying something
and the [ __ ] guy in the boat it
wasn't even a boat that was like one of
those huts
that's just like it's like a newsstand
kind of but not a newsstand
i don't think they have like regular
like they don't have permits or whatever
he's like yeah no no no no no no no no
you're not taking him so then you got
the quarters
i broke the [ __ ] steel out you want
to play hardball
put the chips on the table the two
dollar bill back in the day
i remember when they went out of
circulation well look i was probably
like five i think they're still in
circulation aren't they
they stop making no when they get they
don't go back out into circulation
well i don't make them and then when
they get to a bank they keep them i
remember a random like older cousin or
somebody like that trying to hit you
with one of those
and you look back now you're like
[ __ ] cheap [ __ ]
that's all you were again was it too
just a random like distant
like older cousin there you go was it
for a gift or just like a
just whatever okay yeah it's cheapo
yeah it's real cheapo it's like magic
cheap magic tricks
magic tricks at a party uh
oh good yeah certainly never used it as
currency
ever i tried since i've been doing
comedy i've tried
like in my adult years i try to use a
two dollar bill i still have it they
used to have 500
i don't remember those i'm talking like
the 30s they have 500. well then you
don't say
you said it like you used them like they
used to have 500.
yeah they used to have a billion dollars
but shut up they did
yeah yeah they had a billion i got one
you do yeah we're gonna frame it
um all right this is pete's second one
which is funny is
drinking ovaltine class or trash they
were talking about this it's 100 classy
when did we talk about this
no no they were talking about it online
oh you might i might have saw that in
the thing oh maybe
ovaltine's [ __ ] classy ice cold milk
in the morning
a lot of nutrients fantastic but you're
on record as saying any sort of powdered
chocolate milk
is trash teen and uh what's it called
carnation
instant breakfast is different what
about tang then i love tang
the mug is round foley's round why don't
you call around
call it foley team uh i didn't [ __ ] with
until my stepmom came around
she started it i was just like that's a
you thing like she would make it every
now and then but yeah i'd have it but
like
i ain't i ain't measuring the powder and
stuff so it's give me to
give me the liquid it's giving it a slim
huh
you drank those yeah he shot gundam yeah
i got that for sure dude man i did i
just thought it was like a milkshake i
didn't know it was like a [ __ ] 4
000 calorie meal there is no fatter
suburban kid move
than drinking your mom's
[Laughter]
slim fat peanut butter jelly sandwich
epitome
of a slim fast and a fresca chaser
that's the epitome no i was a fat kid
with repressed feelings in the 90s i
would have
nobody was there to care
[Laughter]
and that's why you were doing it
that was some [ __ ] salty pretzels
good at night for a while
it was later on my mom got these uh
they were they they were like chocolate
nuggets but they were
they weren't they were something some
kind of like fiber or protein
or something that you were only supposed
to have one of them like every three
days
and they were so i like the vitex things
or something they might have been
fighting
something or something boom boom boom
boom me and my dad and brother
crushing them like it was november first
baby
after halloween yeah she had she had to
get rid of them yeah
we used to be we used to have power bars
but i used to eat like 10 of them at
once mom how strong am i
he's lived in the couch
henry put down the garage mama i had
like three powerboards
but when i was stoned i used to prefer
power bars over regular candy bars
because they had a better chew
yeah it's a real fat kid moves yeah
but a couple power bars and an nice cold
gatorade [ __ ] biting and sniffing
that
it's pretty good um all right we gotta
we gotta wrap up so let's do a couple
more a couple of quickies uh
this one's just [ __ ] this one i took
from twitter it was so good you were
tagged in it too if this is from no name
game guy have you ever paid for assembly
for furniture a new grill etc
which i think is classy right paying for
the assembly's class if you're a young
doctor
yeah it's classy to have it done right
like hey come take
that's like the same as like fixing your
own roof if you don't know what you're
doing is trash here no no no no no
i've dude i've put together a lot of
furniture i've never successfully put
together the first you know what looking
back on my family history
yes um how um and i'm not talking about
building a deck like my dad could do
that
no i'm talking like a bookshelf he could
build a deck but when i leave something
like that
anything where ikea was involved a
dresser a bureau an arm war or something
when i look back on the fights and
arguments that something
yelling and and the end result of the
product
being poorly constructed yeah a couple
of screws left over having somebody do
it is the right the right way to do it
and they they did kind of get on that
tip for
for a while yeah i feel like in like the
early 2000s
the handyman really started to kind of
resurface a little bit i don't know i
haven't been tracking the
every man i don't know i remember all of
a sudden there was you know like we did
have people
there was guys that you would hire that
would do [ __ ] like that guys that like
went around the burbs doing like
not odd jobs but they weren't like a
general contractor yeah they're like hey
you got a window i can tighten that up
yeah this is taskrabbit yeah yeah yes
exactly
so yeah you know what that is classy
that's what i think it's like
the trashier way is to be like ah i'm
not paying for that that's how they get
you it's like no it's the right way to
do it
yes you know yes although we did we hung
our tv
and we felt really good about doing it
yeah because we went out and got the
proper tools we got the [ __ ]
the stud finder and really it really it
was the first time sure but this is what
i'm saying most people don't do that
you're like oh i got the ikea drill in
there
like most people are just eyeballing and
not doing the stud finder
of course that's what i'm saying yes so
if you do it right is normally what i
would do
yes which we're predisposed to be like
ah [ __ ] like even this the the tv here
i was gonna [ __ ] do it myself and i
was like i'm just gonna have [ __ ]
ryan come on yeah i've never put like a
dress or anything like that together
where
like something wasn't i didn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and like have to get a hammer
and like [ __ ] really match it [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ]
i hate it all right let's do two more
here
uh speaking of gifts uh all right so
this is from facebook uh the facebook
group shout out to that [ __ ] facebook
group baby it's cooking you guys are
[ __ ]
annie miles uh this is from john
cavenis uh have you ever purposely left
the price tag on a gift for someone
which i just bought a gift from my other
nephew like two weeks or a month ago
and i kind of wanted to because it's
also like who can't like trash
if it's expensive enough it wasn't
that's the thing i'm like who am i
hiding
i'm hiding this from a five-year-old he
doesn't [ __ ] know
well did you see it and leave it on
purpose because that's weird
i was trying to get it off and it wasn't
coming off
and i was just like i i i mean kids are
involved though
obviously but they have they should
that's when you should leave it on they
have no understanding of money
i want you to know uncle kippy paid 6.95
for this
no it wasn't even it was like 39 bucks
for 29 but whatever it was
you were face throwing no but it was
just your favorite
six-year-old you're taking you you're
not understanding my point i'm sitting
there and i'm taking it off i'm going
to money is a waste of time yes but
that's not what the question is the
question
is leaving it on as a face throw yes oh
no okay well then i wasn't but also okay
now i don't know i like a good
face-throw
i love it oh come on it's the only thing
this pandemic's been missing
that's gonna be that's gonna be a gift
that's like 150 bucks and you want
people to know that you spend 150 bucks
right that's what
that's where that would come in if a
gift is truly classy like a [ __ ]
diamond bracelet or a [ __ ] nice ass
watch motherfucker's gonna know a rolex
is expensive you don't need to leave
what i'm saying if i would if i were to
buy foley a [ __ ]
uh you know gi joe a gi or a pair of
shoes or something
like he's gonna know how much i spent
he's not gonna go oh these were 29.99
i'm like no they were 300 pair of shoes
uh
i prefer the gi joe yeah sure i'm just
saying but it's like at what point are
you receiving something where you're
going
i got no clue how much this cost
where you know every gift you received
if you receive a video game you know the
exact price of that
if you receive a [ __ ] camera you know
the exact price of that
it's nice because i'm turning them i can
i know what i'm getting t-boned this
and i'm getting close this this nephew
must have done something to piss you off
i don't know my mom paid i had my mom's
credit card anyway so it didn't matter
[Music]
no i don't think so but i have i have
over spent
just for the face throw like on wine and
stuff like that
sure you know what i mean all right chaz
relax
uh i have all right let's do one more
here
uh let's see let's see let's try what a
fun app it's been a hot one
love the family apps yeah man uh they're
getting better at the questions than we
are
i like we did the oh this one's great
all right this is this is the one i was
looking for this is from donovan mooney
have you ever peeled off the factory
decals on the back of your
car to make it look more sleek you know
what i mean like taking like fred beans
off or whatever so like
it's it looks like more like a [ __ ]
uh that's like a shakery car
that's like [ __ ] trimming your eyebrows
it can you go too far yeah you can
because i've seen
cars i've seen like a proper honda
accord that it didn't
none of that was all gone the h was gone
the accord was
and it just looks weird mm-hmm it looks
right that's like the guy here
looks real suspect that's the guy who
puts like the straps in the front of the
car too
to make it look like you ever see that
or like it looks they get towed that way
never mind you guys straps yeah they'll
put like two like hooks or loops in the
front of their car
uh-huh for like that it's like a race
car
and that's how you tow the car via those
straps you know
what i've seen i've seen like bucket
seats with like the racing similar
those the similar people have those same
things why do you have to tow a race car
like onto the trailer yeah or like yeah
because you don't like cruising a racing
car around you move a race car
sure so that's the idea and they make it
look like oh this is a car
and they have like the two hooks in the
front or whatever or maybe it's to not
mess up like the body the kit that they
put on the phone
yeah like if you're gonna tow it throw
it in this is the thing i got a race
coming up
yeah it's it's a [ __ ] corny looking
don't damage that that's what yeah
everybody knows real racers keep their
nos tanks in the seat next to them yeah
yeah the ejection button under the am fm
radio button
i couldn't wrap my head around what that
is or what that does it just makes you
go faster
sure that's it okay yeah i mean what do
you think i was gonna [ __ ] break out
a chart
i mean yeah it makes you go fast i don't
[ __ ] know i've seen fast and furious
it's like a red bull for your engine
it's a sugar-free red bull for you
fantastic wrap it up gang listen we love
you guys thank you so much
uh thank you for all the love all the
support and uh kippy what do you got for
him that's it guys just put uh i'm at
kevin ryan comedy on all social media
those numbers are [ __ ] starting to
cook
too you guys are starting to get on
board uh and then uh please make sure
you subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube patreon.com
and come check us out live we're gonna
be announcing maybe when this comes out
we're gonna be announcing like 11 more
dates
throughout the [ __ ] country all
summer all over we're looking to [ __ ]
see you guys
we love you guys at each foley on ice on
twitter and foleygrams on instagram
tobymcmullen on instagram tobywell and
follow the podcast
are you garbage get us a 10k so we can
get the swipe up we know how many
[ __ ] listen to this podcast
yeah and you ain't contributing to
social media numbers i'll tell you
that's what we need is a new for a new
campaign need a new swipe up campaign oh
yeah maybe
10k to the swipe up get us swipe up yeah
team
we love you guys we'll see you next week
peace